[Music]
foreign
how do you become a dude that is trusted
by these guys to say hey this is the
kind of guy that could get five to ten
thousand actually you know do this big
big job for us like how do you earn
their trust I mean I don't think you
ever do because even that even them
they're um disposable too they're
they're they're all the people that I
knew over there I'll say like 85 are
gone already
they're either their M.I.A they're dead
they're they're over they got indicted
they're over here in the U.S doing life
like
like their shit's not even guaranteed
nothing's guaranteed over there you know
like the cops are corrupt and then they
got good cops and then they got cops
that don't know they're corrupt they're
doing their job but they're working for
someone but they don't know because
their boss works for somebody so their
boss is going go hit that house but
they're really hitting their enemy's
house somebody else's you know so how
many years are you there I was there 15
years wow so you know in those phones
right yeah that's what's that you was on
the run during that whole 15 15 years
and you know the the whole time I was I
was I dropped 80 albums I was recording
music crazy when I was over there you
got the pressure of being on the Run
being wanted for murder and then is
there also there's also this pressure of
your enemies or the things that you've
done coming back to haunt you over there
yeah no there is and at the same time
it's like you're living your life like
like [__] that happens in your in
regular you got to deal with all the
life things too like regular life [__]
like life things were happening getting
over there like regular life things you
know it's not all like
[__] Narco season two and [__] you
know it's not all that it's it's life
and then and love and sadness and all
these like things that mess with your
heart and life's changing and you're
changing too you know my boy
here came out to Faith I met him over
there
and um
he's like hey we have a group where it's
all all nothing but homies but they
learned all the ceremonies they're in
the feds directly from the lakota's from
the shoes
and we run our own sweat lodge over here
and uh and and you know we're inviting
you we it's private no one's not allowed
to come but we're inviting you you know
because he knew that I was all [__] up
this shit's [__] [__] I had a lot
of problems so they invited me to the
sweat lodge right
and when I get there they tell me you
know what we're going to run this sweat
we're going to run this sweat for your
sister
and um we you know I I had to sweat it
in a lot of years because I had sweated
with the with the Lakota as long as my
boy wrote a book and he was real close
with the Lakota so he took me to a sweat
with him a long time ago
so I go to this sweat and um man [__]
was hot as [__] like satanic level like
tell me about that what's going through
that so we go to the sweat you know
round one kicks in boom and [__] gets
hot as [__] where are you like I'm in
Baja I'm like right on the beach this
area is called Baja Malibu walk us
through like people who don't know what
a sweat lodge is sweat lodge is like
this it's like a ceremony it's like this
um the coin nippies in Spanish they you
know Latin America they call it the
mascal where it's basically like like
they put these Hot Rocks they hit these
rocks and they put them in the middle
and then they pour the water on it and
then it's like a ceremony inside tents
it's sort of like the tent but it's like
round it's almost like an igloo but it's
like they make it out of Willow because
you could ban Willow and then they cover
it all with blankets and then in there
you know they're drumming they're
singing these songs and then you know
you like invoking the ancestors and
basically it represents going back into
the womb
so you go back into the womb or the
Earth and then you sweat and then and
then you know a lot of things happen in
there like you know it's psychological
too because you start hearing voices in
your like me that's my experience I
don't know if everybody
like me I'm in there and all my problems
like all my demons come out in round one
because it was hot as [__] how long is
round one maybe about 20 25 minutes it's
hot as [__] so the whole sweats about
like two hours
you know it because in between they take
a break they open up the wind the the
door
and then while they're bringing in the
next set of rocks so every round was
getting hotter and hotter you know
and like by round three I'm out I'm
almost laid out on the floor like I've
been shot or something you know and and
so I'm saying like it's like you're out
to me it's like a test because some
people tap out you know but you're not
allowed to tap out with the homies
because it's like almost like a sign of
disrespect you know like nah we're in
here because basically you're going like
the way they they the way I learned it
from them they're in there to suffer for
to suffer and and
you know so uh you're in there suffering
you know you're in there like for the
ones that were here the ones that are
here now and the ones that are yet to
come and and you know your ancestors and
all this stuff you're hearing all these
things but all your problems pop out
right there for me and they're in I feel
like they were in the sweat lodge with
me you know
and then um
like I said they ran that sweat for my
sister
so every like man we're gonna we're here
to sacrifice and and
they kept on bringing on my sister and
and you know it was beautiful it was
hard it was man that's one of the
hottest sweats I've ever been in you
know like I could name three and that
was one other one it was hot as [__] and
and it took everything out of me
everything everything like basically
almost dragged me out of there after it
was done
and then it was right next to the ocean
so we just go jump into the ocean and um
and it's crazy because nine months later
my sister had her son Matthias and we
always call him the sweat lodge baby
yeah nine months later exactly you know
so
and and it was things like that like
spirituality started coming into the
picture you know
and and I already have been initiating
to the Afro Cuban religions one by way
in Nigeria the other one by way of the
Congo Angola whatever and and they were
giving me hope I was new so I was like
well what to say what's what the God's
talking about am I straight oh yeah if
you do this if you do that and and you
know but it's full of like um charlatans
too you know so but me I'm a reader I
like to read and study you know so I
started like you know studying and find
out that it's real practical just
because it's it's like it's your Reuben
or spoken in Nigerian you think you're
hearing all this [__] you're like the
[__] are they saying you know it sounds
like like how somebody would say he's
talking Chinese or what but you know
you're in this African language but when
you really break it down and you
translate it it's just you're just
venerating like like
like the world like everything in it the
water the the air the you know fire like
you just you know you're just some
giving
thanks to the gods for all these all
these things that we we don't even give
a [__] about them you know we take them
for granted and [__] and and then so you
know I started sweating
and I started I ended up sweating like
for like seven six years seven years I
don't know like once a month I was sweat
I would just sweat it I I got like
addicted to it like you still do it yeah
I mean I don't do it as much as as as as
as I used to and as I can because now
it's in Bala so it's it's a mission for
me but they're still running on the same
everything's still everything's still
running you know but I think that was
like a change and then all these dudes
that I'm around they're all spiritual
but all these dudes are ex Killers X
dope dealers all of them all of them had
all of them that came from the feds 125
130 115 110 all of them had double digit
numbers like behind behind them you know
so and I like that you know even the
afro-curing religion is like I told you
like it'd be like hitman's prostitutes
[__]
you know government officials in the
religion I'll be like man I like this
because there's nobody tripping on
nobody I could be next to this guy
he don't care and now I'm homies with a
[__]
Governor's assistant and I'm my boy's a
cop right here and now this [__] I'm
using all this [__] to my advantage now
like it's keeping me up on game because
I'm still a fugitive I'm still got all
these issues still going on but now it's
like
now they're my people another like
they're like giving me insight and and
hey well look it's about to get hot
right now there's this and that or or or
I just listen without asking and I hear
things you know and I'm like oh [__]
it's time for me to you know go on the
ground again for a little bit or
whatever you know in your life I see you
did a lot of soul searching yeah trying
to find direction
have it ever been that moment in that 15
years where you thought it was over with
yeah it's coming up
but I still have problems so I still
have to keep that I have to keep that in
the cut just in case I needed Plan B
Plan B I always have to be
in here somewhere in case I needed to
reach for Plan B
so so plan B being I'm gonna take the
fight to them yeah yeah if if I have no
choice because sometimes they'll you get
cornered in over there if you don't do
plan a you're most likely going to get
cornered in with Plan B
so
and sometimes you do plan a and they
know where you're going so plan B chases
you to wherever you your destination
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
the idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and given the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]